[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'était hier à
montpellier au moment de la clôture des
journées euro med sin 85
le professeur cabrol qui fut le premier
français à transplanter un choeur a
choisi la fin de ces importantes
journées médicales pour sortir de son
légendaire silence et lancé un appel en
faveur des donneurs d'organes et
singulièrement de coeur en effet pour
sauver des vies on manque toujours de
coeur dans notre pays
pourtant grâce aux considérables progrès
de la médecine
la transplantation cardiaque est sorti
du domaine expérimental deux chiffres
pour vous le prouver s'il le fallait on
a réalisé plus de 1000 greffe cardiaque
dans le monde et pas loin de 300 en
france pour la centaine de transplantés
cardiaques qui vivent aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'autres beaucoup d'autres
malades qui n'ont souvent que quelques
mois à vivre sont dans la tente
faute de coeur qui relie pour un seul
hôpital français la pitié salpêtrière on
en est déjà à plus de 150 greffe du
coeur dans le service du professeur
cabrol dont 40
l'année dernière seulement résultat plus
en plus satisfaisant 8 opéré sur dix
semaines une vie normale la moitié
reprennent leur travail
les progrès sont lus à de meilleurs
diagnostics des interventions plus sûr
et l'apparition d'un médicament anti
rejet très puissant
la cyclosporine enfin à de meilleures
sélections de receveurs et donneurs
mais précisément le succès appelle plus
de donneurs le problème c'est que
maintenant que la transplantation
cardiaque à d'excellents résultats
ça c'est ça c'est parmi les les
confrères médecins ça c'est parmi les
malades
par conséquent nous nous voyons beaucoup
de personnes qui en ont besoin qui
viennent nous voir et ça dépasse pour
l'instant les possibilités il faut donc
avoir des donneurs il ya malheureusement
en france
trop de personnes qui meurent chaque
jour en tout cas bien suffisamment pour
couvrir tous les besoins des
transplantations
ce qu'il faut c'est c'est pouvoir
utiliser les organes pour utiliser deux
organes il faut comme pour la
transfusion sanguine il faut un un élan
véritablement de tous
il faut comprendre que si on meurt dans
les circonstances on peut prélever ses
organes il faut les données je pense que
tous on devrait comprendre que si on est
on veut avant des circonstances qui
permettent le prélèvement il faut donner
ses appels il faut avoir sur soi un
témoignage puisque c'est la loi
maintenant un témoignage qui disent que
nous sommes prêts à donner nos organes
en effet le nom du coeur il est
important de le prévoir avant le drame
de la mort
lorsque celle ci survient ni le médecin
ni la famille ne sont en état de prendre
une telle décision
[Musique]